so let me start by saying I've seen the
first five episodes I loved it
it's just great oh so here's the thing
would mind wine crap like it's either
like we're buddies I would say and it's
either not my favorite or like or loved
it you know that's when I was like when
it's not your favorite then I'm like all
right dude forget about it mom I'm not
even gonna read the review right you
know what's funny and and I say this all
the time like um so I have an amazing
staff that works for Collider and
there's such better writers than I am I
can't compete with my staff they're
amazing which is why they are the
reviewers yeah so you used to do that
like many years ago I might have done a
review or two but it is my again the
watch I don't let's move past all that
and let's jump into I get to talk to you
that so first of all how did you first
get involved in this thing were you a
fan of the show let's start with that
yeah you know what I wasn't a fan of the
show so you not seen any no no cuz I'm
like you know my kid he's ten now but
what I talked to I know time flies I
talked to Eric Newman like three years
ago
my kid was like six and a half or
something like that so basically all I
watch was like Toy Story and wreck-it
Ralph and you know kids movies and
things like that
so I tell I said I'm very sorry I hadn't
watched the show I heard it's amazing he
pitched me Kiki Camarena then I went
home saw two episodes and immediately
called my reps and I was like dude let's
totally chase this I didn't I can't
believe I don't know this this show and
then when they you know said that it was
I'm like i binge watch like 18 hours
like you know we could have I mean for
me that's a lot sure a lot of content
what was it like making this show
because it seems like it listen it's
very intense yeah and you're watching
there is some crazy action there's
violence there's serious dialogue
moments yeah yeah I mean well this show
is crazy because it's you know you you
realize as soon as you get in the Mexico
that you're American it doesn't it
doesn't matter and and some of the
places are pretty sketchy but we had
security or whatever but if you just see
the land the land is not
the easiest to live off of there's I
mean there's some really really poor
people there with no government
assistance whatsoever and because
there's poor people there sometimes
crime you know and you know if they see
you with a fancy watch I'm sure they
want to get it but it was it was crazy
man like I had the job because I was
investigating and I had to go everywhere
where I had to go to Waddle ahora
Jalisco get at that oh all these
different places you know just trying to
chase the cartel there I'm curious how
many scripts did you you must have known
the arc of the story when you have mine
done how many scripts did you have prior
to filming the first one we only had two
scripts and and in those like those two
scripts it was funny because in every
binge worthy show the first two I don't
know I want to hear your thoughts on
this first or normally the the
establishing ones right they're good but
its episodes three and four that really
start cooking and so I was just you know
it was an establishing episodes sure
well I mean it starts the very first
episode starts with you have a narrator
on the show basically saying this is not
going to end well yeah exactly the right
from the guy that I'm abducted and then
I have a hood over my head right and so
it's it's kind of eerie and then they
the cops
you know lead you you know the local
police lead you know help the guys the
kidnappers it's not it's not a good
feeling
no and see no I'm not sure what you can
say and I'm not sure what how much you
can say but is this one of these things
where your storyline is wrapped up in
one season or is it one of these things
that could it it's further can't say it
right sorry man I'm sorry
off the record I'll tell you sure I've
so many things you know you'll be able
to watch it in two days believe me sir
it's being watched this weekend the sir
the right did the wrestler from one can
write the the rest of the show is this
weekend how is it though because the
dialogue and the the writing on this
show is so good how is it onset in terms
of are you guys changing things or is
you guys hitting every comma well I mean
I I definitely do like to change certain
things like eat I like I know what that
you know what they want to accomplish
and also the story points that they
to hit and I would just sometimes
sometimes change it so that I could try
to make a scene out of it
you know what I mean because it's um you
know like just like with any other movie
like you want the the motivation to be
well intact and you and so I needed to
for sure delineate between just a
general like oh he's focused and he
wants this but why does he want it so it
almost like building the resentment you
know from all the things all these and
justices that who have been left and
right for me we're building and building
and building and then I you know that's
why I was like I almost wanted like
revenge it felt like sure that your your
you're playing someone who is really
like morally centered yeah you know and
a paper that sound that that's like an
action hero and I don't want to play it
play an action hero so that that's why I
needed to justify it and rearrange
certain things and ya know but what also
what is it like playing someone like
that because I mean it's it's it's just
an interesting character and obviously
based on someone real yeah but it's just
very morally centered and you know
there's a great line about how he went
to break something up in a bathroom and
you know that was a real story like they
went to go break something in a bathroom
like you know there was a couple guys
smoking weed at the time when it was but
they were like you know bad guys and
they beat him up and so he got him and
he was asked if it was worth it and he
says the real guy said yeah was worth it
because not only did he get him for
possession but he got him for assault
right and these guys were the ones that
were constantly you know somehow evading
you know they had these drug dealers
hired really good lawyers so they never
got their due justice so it was he was
glad to finally get these guys before I
run out of time with you I believe
you're playing a dad in an upcoming Dora
movie or am I wrong about this now
you're right about that right so I'm
like I thought I thought like it took so
long for that question like dad I'm like
I am a dad well eventually I'm gonna get
good at my job and actually love what
I'm doing but
till then no so have you started filming
that yet and what has it been yeah I
filmed it already you know it like it
was I was in Australia for like three
weeks and I took me I was but you they
said that there was a day normally lie
to me
no no that's a good cabinet I know I
just say that I do yeah
so when they told me about a Dora
project I wasn't super excited about it
but then I read the script and then it's
the guy that directed the Muppet shows
james bobin yep James Wow yeah exactly
him and he directed Alice Through the
Looking Glass and I thought those movies
are so badass then I thought oh I think
this could be really cool especially
with it's a good script to my last thing
for you are you doing this Fantasy
Island movie is this happening yeah I
think so
I think so hopefully it's in January oh
so it's like really going yeah Jeff
Wadlow is direct write the script and
again it's it takes you know the the
general idea of the basic idea of
Fantasy Island and then and then adds to
it which I always am a huge fan of yeah
I'm very curious on that note I cannot
wait to finish this always a pleasure to
see you always
you